the cumulative effect of this show would
would have a potentially very bad impact
on you and we don't want that
your safety is paramount
we can't do it
we can't
castaway jackson fox forced to leave
survivor season 42 after just 48 hours
into the game and it's all due to
medical information he disclosed late to
the show you're deprived of every single
thing it's the hierarchy of needs and
it's survival here's what happened jeff
probst pops up at jackson's tribes camp
out of the blue it's something the host
rarely does on the show i came here with
a purpose and it was to have a little
one-on-one with jackson jeff tells the
texas native he was an excellent
candidate for the show except he kept
something secret he shouldn't have
during the casting process
there's another element throughout the
casting process where we ask you to
always keep us updated on anything that
changes with your medical situation the
day before we're gonna shoot
you
disclose some new medical information
and we all decided
let's
let jackson start the game okay because
nothing's going to happen in 24 or 48
hours that new medical info jackson
takes lithium a medication used to treat
mental health conditions
now here's why jackson says he didn't
disclose his prescription before filming
because i remember talking to my wife
she's a nurse and i said
i'm a lithia but she's like well you're
weaning yourself off of it you'll
probably be off of it it's astigmatism i
mean i'm a human to know the fear is
everyone hears the word lithium and they
go way back in time where they're like
that was a huge drug back in the day
that was a scary drug to be on this all
comes after jackson revealed even more
about himself announcing to his tribe
mates that he's a trans man
jackson actually first tried out for the
show a decade ago when he was living as
a woman the first thought is the
transition
was it because your transition i'm like
i didn't i had nothing to do with it if
that were the case i would have done
lithium 20 years ago because i was so
unhappy but that wasn't the case
i took it for another reason now jackson
makes it clear taking lithium is
unrelated to his gender affirming
treatments it's actually to help him
with sleep issues and anxiety the result
of being the primary caregiver for his
ill mother since 2016. and i wasn't
ashamed to say that i was on something
because i don't know how anybody could
go through what i went through and be
like i don't need anything i'm fine but
due to the effects of getting off the
medication jeff tells jackson he cannot
continue his journey still the 48 year
old health care worker couldn't be more
grateful for his short experience i get
it
and i appreciate you talking to me about
it
it's weird that i'm getting emotional
about it but even to test yourself for
48 hours it is such an adventure
and i appreciate it it was the best 48
hours i've had
ever and it was an emotional goodbye
when jackson broke the news to his tribe
who he clearly left a mark on as much as
i would love to be here
[Music]
they're gonna have to take me out
it's a journey that i was absolutely
blessed to be able to go on
and i think it makes you stronger and
more adaptable to what life will throw
at you so i think even if you don't win
a million dollars you've won something
that very few people
can say they've done and telling stories
like jackson's is why jeff thinks
survivor is still so fascinating to its
viewers after 22 years on air we spend a
year looking for the people to play and
people go how hard is it to find weirdos
and crazy people no they're not they're
actually really compelling interesting
three-dimensional people who have
stories that they're trying to figure
out out here in the jungle
and i feel like over the last few years
we've even gotten better at telling
their stories you're hearing more people
say wow they really grew they changed
they evolved
[Music]
you